this is the iced coffee hour welcome
back my name is doug
and so far i think it has made
sixty five thousand dollars add revenue
that's the first one in a while it's
been lower that was yes
everyone is funny everyone says higher
higher keep going
166
230 dollars why do i have a podcast you
gotta do it it's a lot of work you know
it's not though it's so much fun see
this is relaxing to me we just filmed a
main channel video before and the entire
time i was panicking uh because not only
do i go in nervous like to meet you
because i've watched you since 2014 with
those ferrari videos i was like nervous
going into it but i'm more nervous about
like something doesn't work the audio is
going to mess up the camera's going to
mess up so i feel like this is more
casual yeah well because if it messes up
it's on jack
true very true
it's stressful for me your main channel
is
so this then then i get angry at chat
like well it's jack's fault so i could
just relax that is interesting man i
should have a podcast
the problem is i got a lot of stuff
going on
yeah but i do think sometimes that i
should have done a podcast instead of
cars and bids would have made life a lot
easier
but then you get guests yeah that's true
about stuff that is a challenging thing
right beginning
yeah
yeah in the beginning it was very
interesting uh and very easy because
everyone was new and it's so simple to
call up hey andre you want to come on
the podcast be over in 15 minutes jeremy
what are you up to today come on over
once you get through 30 of those people
yeah i would say the first
maybe the first like 10 to 15 were i
thought simple but then after that you
have to really think strategically about
like is this a guest that once you build
an audience do they do they care about
this person how could it be interesting
how could you spin it and there's some
people that we want to have on it's just
we don't know how to how to integrate
that within the existing audience in a
way that people want to see yeah that
makes sense that makes sense and plus
probably some people aren't
interesting enough for a full podcast i
imagine like they have a thing they can
talk about
that's the thing
not to but sometimes yeah like we do cut
episodes short or we can put two people
in one episode
you know so tell us for your audience um
for the audience that isn't familiar
with you i have to say you're one of the
few people who i've been so excited to
meet oh thank you really appreciate it
because i've been into cars since uh it
was when i saw lotus elise it was 2005
for 2006 i saw lotus leaves for the
first time in phantom black and i
thought that's the batman car yeah and i
was blown away by and and the owner's
son gave me a ride in the car uh drove
me home one day and uh ever since then
i've been obsessed
so and you had a lot of elise yeah i did
i had on at least i bought a 2006 chrome
orange in san jose in 2012
and dro i lived in atlanta and i drove
it home and it was the worst week of my
entire life driving from the bay area to
atlanta across the country in that car
yeah
you could imagine you know what's weird
is that i bought a chrome orange 2006
also in san jose no way you're kidding i
kid you not that but it was 2009 when i
bought mine
no way what a crazy coincidence i wonder
how many there were the the
i loved that car it was cool but it was
pretty compromised how did you fit how
tall it is
it was fine but it wasn't good yeah so
like you know you're driving through
kansas and you're like damn yeah you
have to be 6'4 right you're not yeah
yeah six like six three six four and
like it was
it was tough it was a tough week that
week yeah
you obviously you had the top on right
so
i had to have a hard top on it because
that was the only way you know it didn't
fit in the car so yeah i mean i did the
whole trip and my mom joined me she
drove with me from vegas to denver where
she lives
and like in retrospect i'm like why did
that happen like she must have been so
miserable for her terrible experience
but i did it and um that was formative
and honest that was before i did any
youtube i just did that for fun yeah and
it was not fun
and especially because there was always
a fear it was gonna break and i mean it
was a disaster in that whole thing but
the car was fine it was cool but you
know i mean car's pretty fragile
it's you're always a little worried
about it the
shell is like one big piece if you
damage it it's a whole thing and
i don't know it wasn't yeah they call it
you have the front clam and the back
clamp right it's like two big pieces
it's like that it's not like cars that
have like panels where if you damage one
they replace it that was like the body
yeah there's no bumper right so if you
scrape the front of the car you
basically have to replace the entire
front of the car in one piece which
happens like often like people get in
minor i had a buddy who like someone
backed into him in a parking lot with
one of those tow hitches or something
and that was it yeah that's the clam
yeah
well that's why that's why there's so
many salvaged lotuses out there yeah you
would actually be able to get a good
deal
would i oh we got to tell you about
jack's car that he just bought we'll
make the announcement here oh wow
sports car oh he did yeah as a
compliment to the 2005 lexus rx 330.
there we go yeah well we uh we have the
mom car right that i can take like
grocery shopping right right
then i have the date car okay uh 2000
mazda mx5 uh se oh nice that's right
massive miata yeah
that's the fancy name
but what you can say you know mx5se you
know yeah
that's a great what color uh it's the
it's like the purple one that i see i
think only comes in one color what uh
manual yes six speed nice that's awesome
it's a great car it's got some big dents
in it but we're smoothing it out right
now the whole point of the car like that
is that you can exactly park it and you
know you don't have to worry every ti
you start getting expensive cars you
start really getting nervous i always
tell people the greatest luxury car in
the world is a relatively inexpensive
car because you don't even have to think
about it i don't worry about it i kind
of drive it like a maniac sometimes but
i'm safe i'm very safe and it's a great
time yeah so have you ever taken out a
luxury car and made a mistake and
scratched it up no never i worry about
it a lot and it's interesting because my
own daily driver car i have a brand new
land rover defender which is a really
cool car and it was expensive 75 000
um and it's scratched and dent it to
hell already even though i've only had
it 18 months i drove it across the
country four times already i've done all
sorts of crazy off-roading with it and i
feel like that's the one car that i feet
that i don't have to worry about
i love that because my entire life is
spent worrying whether it's my own cars
or like the cars that i review of
people's that are usually very valuable
and special and so it's really nice the
the the the ability to not care is just
so nice and i've been richly rewarded
because
the market is insane and that car is
probably worth what i paid even though
i've got some files on it and stuff it's
all worked out pretty well
but no i know yeah the markup on those
cars right now if you walk into a
dealership they'll be like well you
could buy one of these but because so
many other people want to buy them uh
you know 20 grand more my dealer told me
they're asking 25 over 25
because when i bought mine it was kind
of a lull it was the end of 20. this
chip shortage thing wasn't a thing
covered was kind of slowing down
everybody was like okay this is over
they were starting to get to dealers i
paid sticker and i had a couple buddies
that were like honestly you should have
negotiated
and now it's like
yeah you can't you can't do it you can't
do it at all so for those that aren't
familiar with your channel what would
you say you do if you're in an uber and
they say what do you do dog
uber i lie
i'm an attorney
like a data processing
data entry i'm not gonna get a single
follow-up question but if i'm telling
like one of my wife's friends uh i make
youtube that i may review cars don't you
you live well
i do i do i do i do well it depends who
it is if it's someone i'm going to see
often i tell them the truth but i never
want to say that i'm i what do you do i
make youtube videos because everyone
they think pranks
the most common thing is you make money
doing that right you make money your
full time job right that's not only is
it my full-time job
but yeah i um so anyway i review cars on
youtube i have mostly new cars but like
80 new cars and 20 old weird cars and um
i kind of take people on thorough tours
of the quirks and features of the cars
that's my thing
um but yeah god that's that's the one
thing i really really do not like is
that conversation it's too bad it has it
has i don't want to say that like has a
reputation like that but anybody over
the age of even like 35 i would say 35
starts teetering when you say youtube
they don't get it yeah absolutely yes
fascinating you guys have very different
experiences with that than i do because
i'm i'm younger i just turned 20 or i
didn't justify and every time i turn 23
and i say oh yeah like if i tell someone
i do youtube they don't i never have
gotten to follow up oh you can make
money doing this right because my
generation like everyone knows that's
what a lot of people do want to be but
that's just fascinating you guys get
like oh you can make money yeah i live
in a neighborhood of like
mostly older people mm-hmm and
i tell them what i do and they're all
like lawyers and and it's like
the oh the questions are unreal like
yeah where can i find your writing they
just assume i like you cars oh like in a
magazine no because nobody does that
anymore
yeah
no it's a blog
i just like it's a it's an interesting
thing i actually prefer meeting people
and
the interactions with people random
people on the street is always an
interesting thing and they recognize i'm
sure you get this all the time and and
that's always it's always i prefer those
vastly to the people who don't know and
you have to explain it because every
explanation is the same and it is
like
grating i like to be like yeah i make
videos yeah here's how it makes money on
youtube google has ads and
it's just a whole thing but it's always
interesting to meet normal yeah people
who fans and things it's it's
interesting in real estate uh because
going through uh
and now it's less of an issue but when i
first started making like a decent
amount from youtube and you're going and
explaining to uh mortgage brokers or the
underwriter at a bank how do you make
money they don't get it yeah and i
remember trying to explain this to bank
of america their underwriter just truly
didn't understand you were getting a
home loan you mean yes yeah when i was
getting a home loan i was getting a
mortgage and i was showing that the
money was coming in from google and so
you work for google i'm like no i don't
work for google yeah exactly same card
never forget the question they asked was
um
do you have a contract yes they asking
the same thing let me see your
employment contract like it doesn't
exist they're like but they but they pay
you
how much do they pay well it depends how
many views well show us the contract
that says they'll pay you this much for
that much views like it doesn't exist
depends on the ad rates like some months
are higher than others it was that was
the hardest one
getting a mortgage with this being my
career fortunately now i've got a few
years of income you can kind of show and
they're like okay i get it yes but even
still explaining it is like a complete
disaster it's funny they asked you for a
contract i thought like maybe it was a
one-off thing they don't deal with it
that way i mean i assume i think that
they when they see a 1099 person they
assume that you have a contract as a
contractor and so they but like
i just don't get how they don't get it
like i of course i think that because
this is my world and i'm like how could
you not know but a lot of people don't
know my parents still don't understand
it so yeah same when i come back to la
every now and then i'll visit um
the old real estate office not the
oppenheim group but before that at
coldwell banker and a lot of those
agents were like 50s and 60s and they
kind of some of them knew about youtube
some of them didn't but every now and
then when i do see them they'll ask
something along the lines of uh are you
still making videos is that still still
doing that
yeah
yeah
as though it's like some passing thing
oh yeah no i'm over that but first i
want to thank our sponsor ftx jack have
you heard about this cool new thing
called crypto it's an online alex i've
heard of crypto and that's because i've
been buying and selling it all online
with no fees whatsoever with ftx ftx is
a crypto exchange trusted by over 6
million people to buy sell and keep
track of all of their favorite
cryptocurrencies all you have to do is
download the ftx app and boom you can
start buying and selling crypto in
minutes the ftx app gives you important
news updates and news feeds directly
from top crypto projects and every trade
you make over ten dollars you can earn
free crypto and unlike other exchanges
that charge you when you buy crypto
withdraw money or i don't know breathe
probably the ftx app does not have any
fees whatsoever ftx offers a crypto
friendly debit card allowing you to
spend crypto at millions of merchants
worldwide you can also buy nfts on the
fdx app with no gas fees supporting both
ethereum and solana blockchains so start
trading crypto and nfts with no fees
today by downloading ftx with our link
down below in the description again we
have a link down below in the
description to start investing in nfts
and cryptocurrencies with no fees
whatsoever thank you so much ftx for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast yeah there's a question for you
yeah
people come up to me all the time on the
street and ask for car advice or tell me
about a car cause me or whatever
do people come up to you and ask for
financial advice all the time really all
the time what is the conversation i am
shocked uh how quickly people open up
about uh yeah within 10 seconds i know
their net worth how much they're making
uh what their credit score is what
they're invested in i mean they will
tell me their their entire financial
life 10 seconds and i get a good idea of
like what's going on but because it's so
personal it'll they'll open up to so
many other things as well like you know
i quit my job at this i'm doing this
thing right now my net worth went up 30
because i was invested in this and i'm
doing this right now what do you
recommend it's always what what do you
recommend what do you tell people what
do you recommend these are conversations
in the street like in the airport yes um
it's it's buying enough it's easy it's
usually what he would say in his youtube
videos yeah yeah
right you don't be you don't say
entertainment purposes
right but yeah yeah
you don't say like this is conversation
like that's what i would think
i'm so used to it no i'm into it it's
weird for me and uh and sometimes macy's
uh my girlfriend has to pull me back
sometimes because like i'll be
introduced and i'll be like yeah so so
how much you make last year and uh i'll
be like so how much of that did you save
and uh and sometimes it just comes up
like so what's your net worth and it's
so common for me because everyone that i
talk to socially you can't just ask
the people that you're meeting everybody
that i talk to is like oh yeah no no
it's uh yeah my net worth right now it's
5.4 and i'm but that's what i'm
interested i'm really curious about that
it's not you know there's nothing other
than just genuine curiosity so for me
it's normal and i appreciate it right
because it's what i would want to know
yeah but it's not normal right right
another pretty common occurrence like if
you meet a fan is that for granted like
they'll just go up and open up their
wallet and show graham all the other
credit cards
just like what do you think about this i
have this one that does this this one
that does this makes me so proud they
always pull out to discover it's secured
they're like this is my first credit
card because i watched your video four
years ago and i got it i still use it
today and then they pull out the city
double cache like then i use this one on
it and they'll pull out the amex be like
i booked a you know plane ticket on this
and so it's cool it's amazing it's nice
to be able to have that effect and i
have people every day at a guy this
morning cars and coffee currently and
say yeah you know i bought whatever it
was because of you and now it's becoming
i bought whatever it was on cars and
bids like i literally bought the car on
your site which is there's some pride
then you're like okay i hope you had a
good experience but there's some pride
there like it's it's i get it it's like
kind of a cool thing yeah um
it is weird the few times i've had to do
fine but i've done finance videos like
the comments
i think that the car community and the
finance community are not necessarily
hand in hand i think if you're into cars
and into finance you are in that space
but a lot of car people just like
have like no financial sense at all i
did a video about how in today's market
where the interest rate's been what they
saw you should finance yes instead of
pay cash which is like to me a
no-brainer automakers are offering you
know one percent loan i mean it's insane
of course you should every rational
person
and oh my god the comments you read the
comments people are like
some people are like i would never buy a
car finance a car when i pay cash one of
the comments that had like 400 thumbs
ups was like when i pay cash it feels
realer
and i'm like
it's
it's difficult because uh there's
there's a big psychological aspect of
that of like
it's a it's a psychological thing and i
but i try to explain to people that's
not necessarily the best decision and i
think people get like angry that it's
too nuanced yeah so sometimes in in
stuff like that you have to go with the
majority of of when you buy a car like
that you should just pay it off in cash
because it's easier for people to
understand and less people could get
hurt right
now it's careful in the video to be like
yeah it only works if you can have
access to really low interest rates and
if you have the money and you're not
stretching and all that and i think that
a lot of people realize that they might
get into trouble if they just started
going out and financing stuff right so
the video was intended to be about if
you can
pay with cash that's probably when you
shouldn't you know but um but boy did
that
it's
yeah i and
personally finance like that is so
one of my most viewed videos was whether
or not you should get a 15 or 30 year
mortgage and that was one of my first
videos that i made
and
i've never seen people so divisive on 30
versus 15 and there are some people who
are were just so adamant that no you
want to pay it off in 15 years because
then you're paying a smaller amount of
interest even though the interest is
over 30 years and mathematically it
makes sense to take the third year but
sometimes you just have to feed into the
psychological aspect and honestly like
having something paid part of it
if that's how they feel then i guess
that's what they should do because if
they're simply not going to be convinced
and if the psychological aspect plays
that much of a thing and if they won't
be able to sleep at night yeah
such as life yeah when i bought the uh
the ford gt i paid for that in cash and
that was one thing uh that was a year
ago okay a year ago i paid cash for it
but the the reason was i i inquired to
one person to get a loan or want one
company to get a loan and they wanted so
much documentation i was like it's just
i don't want to go through that that
loan process yes yeah it's horrible yeah
so yeah i recently bought a house and it
was such a hellish process that i now
like i for a long time why would anybody
pay cash for a house with interest rates
that they are after that i now kind of
realize
like if you can and if it's if you're
worth 50 million in a 2 million house
you just write a check maybe it makes
some sense you just don't have to go
through all that crap when did you buy a
house i bought a house here in san diego
in 19.
wow okay so good time in in hindsight
actually a good time but it's
interesting we bought the house we paid
the highest price per square foot in the
neighborhood and everybody thought we
were nuts
no they're not thinking that right now
yeah
when when in 2019 do you need to
beginning like start of the year okay
that was a good time to buy because 2018
the the feds started raising rates yep
and the real estate market softened a
little bit and that was one of the few
times where things started going down
just barely and we when we we were under
contract on the same house in 2018 for
more money and we ended up buying the
house for less money when it went back
on the market in 19. so it worked out
well and most importantly obviously
things have gone nuts and san diego is
one of the markets where they've
especially gone nuts this it's
absolutely i've been out of control it's
one of the highest increases um and poi
is an insane but it's insane everywhere
yeah yeah you're probably up 25
i was just gonna ask is that your only
property yeah um it is but yeah i think
25 yeah which is insane
we thought it was inflated then and
everybody else did too all of our
neighbors like this is insane nobody
should pay this
did you worry when covet hit that like
you had just bought a house you had a
business that was online reviewing
people's cars
was because i remember when i i bought a
house
the month before kovit it was the most
expensive i went from an 800 square foot
duplex to a two million dollar house in
santa monica
and the month after covet hit and i
remember i had sponsors all of a sudden
in march sort of backing out say we want
we want to see what happens see how this
plays out ad revenue dropped
substantially i was like oh crap i got
in just terrible timing i was like you
know what
what can i do you gotta yeah i think
that the key is and you know this and
you probably advocate for this you gotta
spend less than you can
you know in case stuff goes bad and that
was my big thing um no i wasn't that
concerned but yeah when copenhagen was
tough just generally i mean you just
didn't know what was going to happen and
i was really worried because we were
trying to get pregnant throughout all of
20 we had a couple miscarriages we were
pregnant when covet hit
and the outcome for women who were
pregnant with kovid was not known and
since it has become known and actually
has turned out not to be all that good
and so we've always been more cautious
than we than i want to be um
and so like i don't want to go to car
like
dealerships which are like the most
conservative organizations like those
guys are like no mass policy no masks
and i was nervous about all that for
sure um and so that aspect was the thing
that that's that worried me the most
like doing these videos with people like
this video here
would not have been even conceivable
during the start of covet like no we
were we were washing pairs
with individual wet wipes like you
remember that world like of course like
everyone was terrified of everything
delivery is it oh yeah yeah leaving the
packages outside for like two days just
just to bring it inside because you
didn't know well you didn't no you
didn't know at the time right exactly
and so i was scared more less about the
channel because i kind of thought it
would come back and honestly i could i
could get a big drop and add rev and
still be okay i was more worried about
like physically going to dudes houses
and like meeting them and
that whole yeah um when you make content
though how much of a backlog do you have
it depends i we spend every summer on
the east coast and i don't film and so
you gotta get a backlog to do that like
a serious so by the time the summer
rolls around like in june i usually have
like 25 videos
which for me because i only put up two
main like two main videos every week
that's two and a half months but you
gotta have it if you wanna do that
that's the one problem with youtube you
can't really take a vacation like
there's no breaks wow
you must have it somewhere yeah so i'm
always two videos ahead on the main
channel okay i'm usually a week ahead on
the second channel
uh the i this this podcast for what
three weeks ahead right now we're three
weeks ahead but don't you usually it's
like one week to just current and then
vlogs are just
those are easy i'll spend 20. i'll spend
20 minutes what do you do when you take
vacations i don't
you don't take vacations you can't i i
took the first vacation in five years to
hawaii for five days and it took me a
week
a week of working probably 12 to 14 hour
days to get five days off but first i
want to thank our sponsor huel alex i'm
so hungry but i don't have the time to
make a healthy meal i guess it's fast
food again jack don't settle for
unhealthy fast food get healthy food
fast with fuel fuel is a meal supplement
with all the essential proteins carbs
fats fibers and 27 other essential
vitamins and minerals i've noticed that
without proper nutrition i become
unproductive and just feel bad and
that's why i consider hewl an investment
not only can it save me time for work it
makes the time i do spend working
actually matter just mix their
plant-based powder with water and you'll
feel fantastic and more efficient for
the rest of your day so recently i've
been working out more as you can
probably tell and i've been drinking
huel black edition which has way more
protein and way fewer carbs to help me
get these insane gains hewl also has hot
and savory meals which include mac and
cheese thai green chili and a few others
you have to try heal is proof that fast
food can be good food i love it and i
know you will too and right now you can
get free shipping on your first order
plus a shaker and a free t-shirt when
you go to huel.com
ich that's h-u-e-l-dot-com
i-c-h for free shipping a shaker and a
t-shirt thank you so much huel and back
to the podcast do you think that there
should be some sort of vacation
compensation from youtube i thought
about this a lot like there's i didn't
get paternity leave you know like in a
job you would and there's no like
advocate for youtubers
because like they're making all this
money they're stupid they're yeah like
and so like but i sit here and think
like is there something to be said for
maybe having youtube be like look you
can take two weeks a year we'll give you
the average of your last two weeks
radrev and like i get obviously why they
don't do it and if you do that they
start to run into some legal issues
because you're right at that point but
by not doing it think about that you
don't have to take a vacation in five
years except when you did one five day
one it took that much work like there's
there's a middle ground that i think
it's more so algorithm-based like i
don't care about the finances at all
it's purely just like come back
is the algorithm gonna be the same and
if i've spent five years working to
perfect the algorithm is taking a week
off going to ruin that yep and i wish if
there was like a pause button where they
could be like you could pause this and
come back in 30 days and your algorithm
will be exactly the same interesting
point i would do that yeah i would love
to take james
but it's always that worry when you come
back
yeah and also with with the content that
i do on the main channel
a lot of it is news based so it's like
whatever happened the day before i have
to talk about the next day and i know
some days where something will happen
and unless i talk about that specific
thing no matter what i post is going to
bomb yeah and then it's going to throw
off the next video interesting so i have
to certain days i'm like if i don't talk
about this i cannot it's better for me
not to post interesting so i'll have to
talk about that that one thing huh how
about that yeah i guess that makes sense
but it's a it's a grind it's fascinating
to me because your videos the production
quality doesn't seem to be like
something out of this world it's very
simple like you said you shoot on your
iphone and you use i think you said a
camcorder yeah so and also the editing
isn't that crazy either right so what's
how how much time lapse is between
shooting the video and then the video
being ready to be it depends on the car
the brand new cars you gotta you gotta
get them up like immediately and
sometimes you have to get them up
immediately because you're there's a
press embargo but for older car videos
they it takes longer um
they're not relevant you gotta get the
new ones up while it's hot it's the same
reason you wanna post news content like
you've got to get it up while people are
interested in it so like ford bronco
raptors got to go up right away and i
got i got videos i shot over a year ago
that are still waiting to go up because
they're cars from the 80s and if i post
it today or if i post it in a year
it's not going to get more or less views
so you just hold those and how much time
is demanded for each process of making a
youtube video whether that be filming
editing
traveling random stuff like that and
also it's a couple hours to it's a
couple hours to research the car write
the script yeah filming is about four or
five hours
and then the editing process thing takes
nick about four hours um
and
then there's travel so like i flew to
michigan to shoot this bronco raptor
that's that's long yeah you gotta be in
michigan in the winter you know and do
you generally do multiple takes per shot
or is it pretty like seamless and
floating um it depends like the mood i'm
in and like
food i had that way you know like how
i'm feeling i'm sure this is the same
way with me some days i wake up and i
know this is a good filming day for
whatever reason i'm like i say
everything perfectly it goes so smoothly
my energy's there totally other days i
mispronounce everything and then you
gotta start it yeah yeah it's
interesting i don't know why that is i
don't get that but there are days where
you are where you just know even before
you start like this is going to be two
hours i'll get a whole video and
sometimes it's like well i've been here
six hours i'm still not through this
but yeah that's an odd one i wonder why
how do you keep so it seems like you're
very just calm
relaxed easy going have you always been
like that yeah i guess really i don't
know i think yeah you get stressed uh
yeah yeah there's a lot
what do you what stresses you out the
problem when you got this is the benefit
of having the channel with with no
employees you don't you're not beholden
to anybody but now i got like the cars
and bids i got like 14 15 people
depending on my
continued success yeah and that's
stressful don't you think like having
employees is like a stressful thing i
mean i obviously i like jack and alex
but i can't imagine having more people
right and i've always just been the type
where i would just do everything myself
yeah
so
there's there's benefit to it and also
you don't you're not like behold like
knowing that people with families are
like depending on you that's like
something jack i view it differently
jack is the opposite i'm not the
opposite i do believe in outsourcing
things that don't necessarily need to be
done and also i do think if you're
constantly doing things that you don't
like to do it's going to make your work
that's true a lot more difficult and
it's going to be like a sprint instead
of a marathon you have to repair
yourself i'm so glad i outsourced
editing for that exact reason think
about it this way the way i like to view
it is a lot of the times what makes
people nervous about editing or
hiring more people is the fact that you
have to find people that are perfect
fits and train them up and stuff like
that but think about it this way if you
could if you could hire someone because
you said your editor's fantastic right
and they were as
diligent and responsible and uh as much
of a go-getter as your editor would you
hire another person if they were just
like that person but they wanted to help
out in another possible to find those
people because those people are already
employed and doing great things right
i'm stuck with
it's very difficult to find those people
but if you could oh yeah yeah yeah sure
and you said during your interview with
graham for the main channel that
you thought it was impossible to
outsource your editing right yeah but
then how many people did it go did you
have to go through
just the guy just the one dude just the
first person right okay you make an
interesting point at this point i don't
really need anybody else but that's what
we did with cars and bids i there were
so many things i did not want to give up
i was like no i'm going to set all the
reserves well that became stupid we get
80 cars submitted today i'm not going to
sell the reserves um
like i want to be the final word on what
the i want to edit every listing that
was for the first couple weeks
that's not real
it became unfeasible and so we i've
learned over the last year that like yes
it can be useful to outsource some of
this stuff and i also am a big big big
believer in specializing and so like my
thing is like i'm good at making the
videos i should make the videos
and other people are good at other stuff
and that's probably what i started like
i got a i got a guy who does my grass
you know my my garden i want
he's good at that if you feel like
you're balanced and you're at a point
where you could do this for 15 20 years
that's totally fine and you probably
have ample employees and you're good to
go yeah so yeah but i'm not like the the
type that's like oh yeah hire aimlessly
just start hiring and bring a board jack
got an intern so jack has his assistant
jack has you a tool
jack has two people working underneath
him
it has improved my work-life balance
dramatically i think a lot of everything
is so much better is that uh
there is a benefit to
the the work-life balance is a i've
learned this as i've gotten older
initially my whole goal was making money
and like succeeding and excelling i
didn't come from a lot of money i never
was in a situation where i had any money
truthfully i mean we were comfortable
but my we never like were i didn't know
anybody with supercar like that wasn't a
thing and it was nice to do that and
then i started to realize what would
also be nice is to enjoy some of it and
to take a vacation you know and
outsourcing i think was a smart decision
and honestly now things have equalized
to the point we've hired enough of cars
and bids i could take back the editing
if i wanted to and probably still be
okay
but i'm not gonna because i'd have a kid
and it's he's it's kind of cool and i
have noodle and i have like my cars i
want to drive my friends and there's
something to that it's worth spending
whatever the editor costs every year to
have to be a proper work-life balance
and to be able to continue to do however
you're doing yeah for the next let's see
but you mentioned the vacation thing i
don't know for me it feels like work is
the vacation like i enjoy like to me
like this would be
the vacation that's great this is my
little vacation that's a great that's a
great position to be in i feel the same
about both work and actual vacations but
that's the best position to be in
because yeah you enjoy what you do you
never you never work a day in your life
right that's like the stupid meme but
it's kind of true yeah and there are a
lot of people who have jobs that suck
yeah but jack outsourced uh i'm just
going to say you're saying
jack outsourced his tinder well that's
that is i didn't know you're going to
say that what did you think it was going
to say i thought you were gonna say i
don't know like cleaning or something
but yeah so
well i guess i have to elaborate now but
yeah i hired a personal assistant and
this person's basically here to just
relieve me of the certain things that i
have to do on a day-to-day basis and
obviously
no obviously but i bought a house back
in october with the house there were a
lot of things wrong with it and i have
to talk with contractors and i want to
put solar on replace the ac unit do all
of this stuff but i've i realized if i
have a lot of stuff going on like a lot
of smaller tasks it takes my mind away
from the big stuff i should be focusing
on so i figured it was worth it tinder
took about worth life balance that's
life that's it
no i did not hire i did not hire someone
out to swipe for me on tinder
i still swipe for myself on tinder and
if i've matched with anyone watching
this right now it is me talking to you
it is me but uh no i uh basically i lost
my tinder account and uh when i changed
phones and i got him to submit a ticket
for me and basically
yeah
i was sitting there thinking you got you
like told the dude all right look i like
this type of person
you know
if you could create a bot though that
does facial recognition that knows like
generally your preference and will
automatically swipe there's more to it
though like it's not just the face like
the bot would also have to like no corny
jokes in the profile you know yeah that
sort of thing but uh yeah that would
actually be interesting to outsource
your tinder my friends and i were just
talking the other day there there is a
race series with ferraris that you call
the ferrari challenge series where you
buy a ferrari challenge race car and
then you drive they there's like
every weekend basically throughout the
summer there's like a race series uh
where you race your challenge car
against other people who have these cars
and obviously it's very wealthy people
who do this and now some of the guys who
do this
have hired a driver so they're not even
racing the car themselves because they
want to win so bad and that's like the
ultimate like ceo move is to outsource
your leisure time
you're not even getting the enjoyment of
using the challenge car they're
literally watching someone else use it
so they can win
and that is a good example of this i
guess oh my gosh so how much free time
would you say you have now um
nights and weekends tend to be to be
pretty free i do a little bit more
traveling for work than i would like to
at the current moment and i don't think
that's gonna stop and so sometimes a
saturday i'll be gone for that or a
night i'll be away
um but
i've tried to focus really on
um
kind of get combining everything into a
typical work day which is longer than
most people's i guess i work from like
six to six um
but that's it
there's no night like evenings i have
with my family and weekends i generally
hang out
have you been surprised with the growth
of the channel so far yeah
i've been surprised this day when i
don't understand
do you
oh yeah yeah
well with with the other channels not so
much now but yeah no the main channel is
the one that yeah i mean
i
i don't get why
um
yeah it is surprising and it surprised
me that you can do this i remember when
i was in college i'm curious to hear
your original thoughts about youtube
before you started doing this because i
was in college they were you heard about
this guy pewdiepie who made a lot of
money on youtube and it was like this
okay but i'm gonna get a job and have
like a life a normal life
and then like it started happening and
it's like i can't believe this is this
is something that's happening especially
to me and probably to you because like
some of our colleagues like wanted to be
youtubers and have always been kind of
dramatic or fashionable or whatever
and so this is a
rational next step for them
but like
isn't it weird when you think about what
you do
based on like your background or like
that this is my career yeah
i don't know it's it's a
it's just what i've enjoyed talking
about though yeah so from but when i
started there was no one else really
talking about personal finance i mean it
was weird to be like i'm talking about
credit cards today guys but what really
said it for me was when uh do you
remember you probably maybe watch him
rob dom yeah yeah he had a yellow
lamborghini diablo and right around that
time i think that was like 2011 2012 he
posted a how he was able to afford a
lamborghini diablo and i watched that
video and i thought it's so inspiring
i wanted to be like rob dom and he was
filming in his garage and i'm like if i
could be able to do that
that that that was it i just knew it and
i messaged rob dom on facebook and i was
just like i didn't know what to say so i
was like oh what camera do you use like
just like the normal stuff just to
strike a conversation and he got back to
me and i was like i think at the time he
had maybe 15 000 subscribers and i was
like oh like this was a big deal for me
to see his respon response and we went
back and forth on uh on facebook and i
asked him i said hey listen i think if
you just if you continue giving business
advice like this you're going to blow up
no because no one else is doing this and
if if you just gave business advice and
practical advice on how to buy a car
like that and you just keep doing that
it's a huge industry no one else is
doing it and he got back to me he said
no i just i'm just doing it for fun and
i just enjoy talking about the car every
now and then i don't want to keep doing
this it's just you know one-off kind of
thing which is true would just remain
true for him like he seems to do it as
like a hobby purely yeah but so you saw
this opportunity yes yeah as soon as he
did that i was like well if he's not
doing it i wanted to do it but that was
2011 or 12. and i never had the courage
i'm like well he has a lamborghini i i
don't have a lamborghini like why would
someone care about what i have to say
right so i just didn't
it's just timing though for you because
like personal finance and taking control
of budgeting and that sort of thing has
become like a really hot in the
especially in the last few years i feel
like maybe it was when i was a kid and i
just wasn't aware of it but i feel like
the internet has given rise to like this
huge culture of
investing personal finance kind of thing
yeah i'm trying to figure out if like
where was the catalyst to that because i
remember when i started in 2017
i was late 2016.
it wasn't a thing yeah and part of me
thinks that maybe it was a bit of the
chase sapphire reserve came out and
that's when i kind of noticed that
everyone was like get the chase sapphire
reserve we're gonna get the points we're
gonna get free stuff
maybe that got people into it
or maybe it was the fact that you know
we had a recession yeah uh people coming
of age after graduating or like now
trying to figure out their finances and
maybe that was like a shift yeah but for
me i just always was into it and i
didn't have friends in person that i
could talk to about credit cards and
personal finance so i'd spend hours on
reddit yeah in the financial uh
independent subreddit and personal
finance yeah just just answering
questions just going back and forth so i
thought that like maybe if i could talk
about this on youtube someone might find
it interesting but no one else was
really doing it yeah are there a bunch
of people now doing it oh gosh yeah yeah
there's there's
it's weird because in the beginning it
was maybe five of us and uh there's a
channel beat the bush we actually
were fortunate enough to have him come
on and he was he's very silly he doesn't
do any collapse uh this is the first
time he's ever done a podcast but he was
the one that i looked to back then yeah
because he was making videos about
financial independence and retiring
early and i remember back then he'd get
like 5 000 views so i thought well if he
could get 5 000 views i know that at
least there's 5 000 people out there who
would want to hear it that's good enough
for me
so it came from that when very few
people were doing it 5 000.
there was another guy his name was brian
casella he had 15 10 or 15 000
subscribers uh giving advice as a real
estate agent and so i looked at him and
i said well if he's giving advice as an
agent i know uh i could probably get 15
000 subscribers if i did the content as
good as his or better and so that this
that was kind of how i viewed that it
made me feel comfortable about jumping
in because at least i'm not the only one
and there's a few other people doing it
too it's amazing to think back yeah it
was that it was like the frontier it was
but it's it's interesting because now it
seems like oh in hindsight yeah it would
have been easy but it's weird because
it's shifting back to niche topics like
back then you couldn't really do niche
topics because no one would care yeah
but then now as i've grown bigger you
have to be more broad in general and so
now it's the niche the niche channels
that are coming back on interesting the
people who talk about so many people are
now watching this that
if you have something that directed that
no one else is talking about you can
yeah like i couldn't make a video
breaking down uh i don't know tesla
stock
yeah exactly it's too niche and it just
it wouldn't appeal to a mass audience
yeah so there's a huge demographic out
there who just wants
tesla stock yeah or just wants the
analysis on one type of how interesting
yeah huh so it's kind of shifting back
and those are the channels now that are
that are kind of growing a little bit
more interesting uh same with
cryptocurrency yeah yeah crypto is
everything right now yeah
do you own any crypto no but i totally
think it's a reasonable thing and i just
i probably should have a long time ago
done it um three years ago i would have
said it was like the stupidest scam bs
in the world but some people who i take
seriously
take crypto seriously and so to me it's
like a fairly reasonable thing do i
assume you do yes i do so i was the
exact same as you uh i thought crypto
was the biggest waste of money i was
like you can't value it right and so i'm
like well the value is only in what
someone else is willing to pay for it i
don't want to put my money in that yeah
but over time um same as you the more
people took it seriously the more i was
like well maybe i should give this a
chance and once i jumped in i was like i
saw the appeal yeah so right now i think
crypto's down so i think i'm about five
to six percent of my entire portfolio is
crypto yeah
so yeah that seems like a healthy i
would do it not financial advice
absolutely but but but for if for good
entertainment you should buy
you should buy one bitcoin and 10
ethereum for a lot of fun
yeah and just that's it just put it to
the side don't look at it yeah one
bitcoin 10 ethereum i just i'm more of a
traditional guy but
bitcoin is rapid or crypto in general is
rapidly becoming more traditional than i
ever would have expected five years ago
some people were way out ahead of that
and i wish i had been of course like
every investment but i've been out ahead
of some other stuff the cars have all
done incredibly well so that's like
again specializing like i kind of knew
what i thought would go up in value and
look what it look what happened you know
it all worked out would you be
comfortable talking about different
percentages and how like different asset
classes reflect your portfolio um yeah
you don't have to disclose numbers but
just percentage and i don't quite know
as much um but i feel like i have a good
i have probably more than i ought to in
the in the market
um just mostly in index funds and stuff
and i think that the i say more than i
ought to even though it's probably half
of
maybe a little more but i graduated
college in 10
and
nobody who graduated college and 10
trust the stock market it just doesn't
occur like everybody thinks that look we
all lived through that i remember
sitting there watching in college i was
a senior or a junior and like bear
stearns is collapsing and lehman is
collapsing and i'm sitting there
thinking
the market is not safe
i'm never gonna get a job i'm screwed
and so like even still to this day i
remember back then
that
cash was a big deal if you had cash in
09 you were you were king yeah and i rem
i thought ever since then like i still
need to hold some cash and i have and
probably more which is funny because i'm
over here thinking that stradman's
insane for doing it and i probably hold
more than i should um
but
i yeah if there's ever another oh nine i
wanna i wanna be able to buy it at 40.
you know yeah
the problem is you won't
when it happens you're scared yeah
that's that's what happened to start at
20 like everything went down and i was
like
you freeze
yeah i've got the cash i could do
something yeah and instead i was like
i'm not buying anything in this market
yes it was interesting jack actually
i think you and i went for we used to
because jack lived with uh he lived in
the guest house right when covet hit and
uh i think it was
march or april we were taking a run and
i had a whole bunch of cash sitting on
the sidelines a whole bunch now i didn't
sell out of anything it's just i was
saving up to buy a property and when the
stock market fell i was telling check
man should i just dump it all in the
markets and i couldn't i mean that would
have been the right thing to do but uh
but the problem is dollar cost averaged
i think beginning late march early april
which was nice probably
not as smart but in retrospect but it
could have been because
in no way there was a drop like that and
you could have dumped everything in and
there was a lot more drop to come and
that's that was my fear and that's why
in order to actually capitalize when the
market is down
you've got to have you got to be willing
to take some risks yeah and i'm just
i'm not like there anymore mentally and
if i never own an f40 even if it gets
cheap again then so be it yeah
that's why it's so much easier at least
for me just to keep buying yeah and so i
have a i have a routine every single
morning i wake up now and i check uh my
account and i buy before i get out of
bed yeah and by the same amount every
single day and then i scroll through the
individual stocks i'm like if one is
down or one looks like a really good
that day buy a little bit for fun yeah
but the majority of it is just smp and
then i'm buying 10 10 to 20 sometimes
international depending on how that's
doing how much is it per day that you
buy
six thousand probably one thousand a day
yeah
when do you cash out this is what i try
to think about like
we've been thinking about make adding an
addition to our house i don't want to
sell anything
it's all no i'm not yeah but at the same
time it's like isn't this what i'm
investing for like isn't this kind of
thing what i'm investing for and i don't
know what to do about that and you could
make the same argument with cars like i
wouldn't mind another cool car but i'm
not gonna sell but at the same time it's
like what if i died and i was like damn
i have less money in the market like an
idiot you know
that's yeah right now i'm starting to
come to terms more with that initially
it was like i need to get some
investments like 10 years ago and now
it's like okay i have them now what like
what do i do yeah i look at the
dividends so it's funny i don't look at
the overall return i just go on mine
there's there's like a little thing that
you could go to it scrolls to show your
estimated revenue with dividends yeah
and so i only look at that yeah i'm like
well you know regardless of what the
stocks are going to be doing i know i'm
going to be getting about that yeah so
that's kind of what i think of mentally
yeah that makes sense yeah and so it's
fun because every day you invest you
watch that number go up just a little
bit and i'm like wow you know today i
got an extra 20 bucks yeah i love that
feeling even if it's like ten dollars
i'm like yeah what can i buy the ten
dollars well if i you know over two days
that's uh sushi right so like every
other day now i get an extra sushi right
so i i find that's fine you actually
reinvest the dividends i reinvest them
right yeah
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
but i i could choose not to i mean
there's a little check of a button you
choose not to but but no i reinvest all
of that right right i don't know it's
interesting i also i feel the same way
and i and i invest not every day but i
have a month number every month or
whatever it is and put in and i always
have and but at some point i'm just like
am i missing out on stuff i should be
doing like on a day-to-day level because
dollar cost averaged so much apparently
and but like like stuff i should be
buying travel i should be doing or
whatever because i put so much money in
the market like this year i told my wife
i don't know if i want to do this house
edition i'd rather invest and she's like
we gotta live
i was like yeah but you know it's
pretty nice you could always create like
a like a fund on the side and say okay
well five percent is going into this
fund and we have enough money then we're
gonna do that that house remodel the
numbers
for what
tens of uh ten thousand dollars five
thousand dollars whatever put in is
in
when we're 60. yes it's just so hard not
to it's so hard not to that's why i've
really prioritized like saving and
investing now because the the
opportunity cost before 40 is a lot okay
but here's the question
you love work yeah
so like isn't it kind of bs like you're
not you're going to want to work forever
yeah so at the end of the day even when
you're 60 and that's a lot of money
still going to work about this a lot but
i love my job i would work as long as i
can
and so i'm thinking like
yeah it's going to end up being a lot
but like
i want to still be working a lot of
people when they do this their goal is
to retire early at 50 or 40 or whatever
but like you and i we enjoy what we do
so much i don't have that goal and so
that's an interesting thing that kind of
changes the
game for me a little yeah but i think i
think
at least for me it's you don't know how
long something is going to last so that
when it's working you may as well double
down on it
because i'd never want to look back 10
years from now be like well you know
it's not working the same as it did back
then the audience if something happened
and i didn't make the most of it
capitalize on it right that's right
because i always looked at it and it's
funny you mentioned uh like like a
highly paid athlete on youtube but i
always went into it thinking the average
youtuber that i used to watch they last
between five and seven years and then
either they voluntarily step back uh the
audience gets bored of them they're not
able to keep relevant and and they just
kind of go go a different way so i've
always seen it five to seven years and i
hit five years so i'm like well in my
mind i'm at that kind of peak point
where you know i'd love for it to
continue but i just don't know don't you
think that we're kind of in uncharted
territory yeah like
a lot of the guys before lasted five to
seven years some of them maybe but even
before was only like five years ago yes
who knows yeah that's that's that's been
my biggest fear is that like even if it
lasts 10 you just you're clueless this
is one of the things i try to i try to
point out whenever people are like oh
you makes a lot of money from youtube
whatever it's like yeah but like if
you're an attorney or a doctor you can
have a pretty good idea that you're
gonna have a career that's gonna span
for x amount of time you're gonna earn
throughout your career and you made
partner and you'll do this or that yeah
um it's not quite as easy when you're on
youtube and like you make a lot in a
very concentrated period of time and it
could end tomorrow and that's the scary
thing how much did you uh did you pay
for your gt 306 wow so yeah and it just
so happened to be one of the most
affordable ones on bring a trailer for
the mileage because all the other ones
and i was i was meticulous about these
numbers when i went in because
you're because you're bidding against
other people and i was so concerned
about getting caught up in the moment be
like oh it's another thousand another or
yeah it was it was i think a thousand
dollar increments and so it's easy to be
like well i'm not going to lose it just
for a thousand dollars and it's easy to
get carried away so i looked at all the
numbers of these cars i think it was
like 310 to 312 was my upper limit from
what i'd feel comfortable spending so
that if for whatever reason i sold the
car i wouldn't take a big loss on it
yeah and uh so in fact how i won it was
very interesting uh we have a friend
anthony and he's a poker player and one
of the things that he would do to throw
people off is he would throw in a bid
with a with an odd number so instead of
betting like here's a hundred dollars
he'd be like 237 dollars right and he
said sometimes when you throw in like a
weird number like that it's going to
throw them off enough
it it it catches them off that they're
less likely to call
and he's like it works uh i've been
doing this for years and so i was
thinking when i'm bidding i'm like what
if i did that the most bizarre pieces of
advice yeah ever hurt but that's how i
won the auction it's interesting the one
time i threw in so i was bidding in
thousand dollar increments and that just
came up in my mind
and i thought well i'm going to bid 1
238
instead of the usual because everyone's
coming up a thousand and that was the
one that won so technically it was like
306
138 or whatever why'd you choose the gt
love the car i love the car i thought it
was a car that people would see
that not only if so first of all from an
investment standpoint i'm like there's
very few cars that are that good for
value so i knew i had to get a car that
was going to hold its value or increase
and i felt like these should be half a
million dollar cars yeah so i kind of
thought for an investment it works
mechanically i like the fact that it was
ford yep and you could go and get parts
yep so i wasn't worried about like oh
man like we have to wait for stuff to be
shipped from italy yep and i also felt
like if i wanted to incorporate it in
some way in the channel so i wanted
something in the backdrop and i felt
well a lamborghini is going to be too
over the top yeah unless they get a
diablo or you know a cool gated
murcielago or a countach but the
maintenance is going to be so crazy on
that and if anything were to happen i
couldn't justify spending that yeah yeah
you know
one of the things that i found about the
car mine
is that um
it is the least divisive exotic car yeah
everyone loves it
people some guys like ferrari some
people like porsche some people like
lamborghini but everyone agrees on the
ford gt yeah somehow it's because it's
because of the history behind the car
and it's seen as like a car enthusiast
car that's right if you're into cars
analog totally i feel the same way i
love that car so much i paid 225 for
mine which is insane how many miles it's
got third now it has eight thousand had
thirty so it was it was a mild car it's
been driven but um
but still there are no more at 225. if
there were i'd buy them um
i love the car so much and i think it's
really really special you know you know
nine
during the worst of it there were some
that sold for under a hundred yeah
yeah
i remember uh in 2010 because this is
2009 no yeah 2010-2011 i think when i
started to buy real estate there was a
lamborghini diablo that was for sale on
ebay and it was sixty five thousand
dollars you know there's all these you
can go back and you wish you could if
40s got to 400 300 yeah nine i mean of
course two and a half now would have
been a good play yeah
but you just never know
and
and like we were saying before you don't
necessarily have i mean i didn't have
the money at the time i'm younger i
didn't have any money for cars like that
back then
um
but also you just didn't necessarily
want to take the risk because it could
have gone lower because you didn't want
to type your cash in here yeah who knew
everything yeah everyone was getting rid
of those cars yeah no one was buying
right no one and a lot of people needed
to sell yeah it was a tough and i
remember the ferrari 360s were hitting
the 50 000 range for a ferrari 360. and
even though those are double that now
yes those aren't even that great
one of those it's not that great of a
car 60s about what it's worth
um no offense to the ferrari 360 crowd
out there no i like that car but it's
not i it's crazy that everything has
gone up in value even cars that aren't
really all that great yeah everything in
life property and yes crazy what are
your thoughts in the car market right
now um just that it is it's over it's
overinflated for the new cars and the
recent used cars the chip shortage stuff
but i really do believe that like some
of these really special cars i think
will never come back down and i think
there's people holding out saying oh
when this bubble bursts i'll pick up
before gt at 200 again they'll come back
down i only it's happening i think that
some of those cars are gone no i've
heard as far as a bubble is concerned
some
companies are giving loans on cars and
people are going to be underwater from
what they own the car versus what the
car is worth
what are your thoughts on on a bubble
popping in the sense that people are
underwater on the cars well i wonder
like
i have been curious about how people are
financing some new cars where dealers
are getting 20 30 000 over sticker at
100 financing right so are banks really
loaning 30 grand over 20 grand over
g-wagon a new g63 is a hundred thousand
dollars over right now if you're lucky
some deals have charged 150 over okay
150 debate that's isn't that double
they they got really expensive are you
serious the sticker on those is like
like 190 now no but people are paying
300 for g63s and not some people every
single new g63 transacting right now is
going 150 over okay every single one you
drive around you see a new g63 that dude
paid 300 000 for that car i'm not exact
or he got really lucky and did it before
any of this happened and even then they
were asking 50 over so then i'm sitting
here thinking what are banks financing
a hundred over
what are people doing like how is this
happening they were curious about that
you know why are they taking out home
equity like what is happening
yeah because it like i that's
interesting i actually never thought of
that because with a house
banks will get an appraisal and so
they'll know based on the comps of all
the other properties it's worth this and
you have to put down right you know 10
to 25 percent and then cover the
difference right if you're paying more
than what the home is worth that comes
out of your pocket but with cars
what appraisal is right there's nothing
that says the the bank assumes that the
the price you agree on with the
dealership is roughly the market price
because cars are relatively common and
that should be the case but like in
today's market there's all these cars
selling defender we're talking defenders
20 over 25 over
that's insane and what happens when the
chip shortage clears those up and
suddenly they're now depreciating like
normal not only i mean the delta is
already pretty bad when you finance a
car that depreciates quickly you already
get underwater sometimes but now it's
gonna be wild
now not everybody is buying cars that
are i think the saving grace here is not
everybody's buying cars that are 20 over
but a lot of people are yeah this market
is totally crazy what was it the the
average price for a toyota camry now was
like 40 something thousand dollars could
you believe that toyota bar is now like
almost 50 something it's like i remember
when i remember when it hit 30 when i
was like 18 and it was a huge deal
look at us now i still think of new cars
and i think like in the 20s right
because i remember like a honda accord
like new like 24 25 and like that's my
threshold so i think 40 right which
shows that we're out of touch with that
but like a civic is now 24 doesn't even
buy you like a nice civic anymore
it's like a base civic like the cheapest
new car is 15 and that has that's a
disaster that's like a chevy sonic you
know it's a disaster oh my gosh that
could be an issue i never thought of it
now the people buying g-wagons
necessarily are not too concerned but
aren't you
there's still an aspect of this whole
like flexing and over-fighting like
there wasn't a wait i don't think it's
going to be
a lot of people think the bubble will
burst and it'll be like oh wait we'll be
in another session i don't feel that way
but there is some crazy stuff going on
is it come on
isn't that yeah come on come on jay
what are your thoughts on nfts speaking
of enemies oh you think that's insane i
don't i don't get it okay what do you
think
one of the craziest things i've ever
seen in my life i think that that gives
us a fantastic proof that we're in a
bubble if you want to proof that we're
in a bubble in some situations i don't
think for all i don't think we're gonna
have another recession i don't think any
of that but if you want another proof
that where like crazy stuff is going
down look at nfts
are you an mft fan no
no i think the digital art i'm
completely against that i love how you
can use it as like a digital certificate
of authenticity i think that's valid and
i like uh that i like the use case of it
but i don't like the whole digital
article who's buying these nfts you hear
some crazy stuff people paid 400 000 for
this or that oh that's cheap now yeah
depending on the nfc right yeah like who
it's not like you usually when you hear
somebody paid two million dollars for a
piece of art you assume it's some very
old person who just has a ton of money
and wanted it but like
that's
i think that market's going to crash
really hard like 99
and it could go up it could triple from
here and then you know i look like i
look stupid until eventually it'll
happen but there's no way there's that
there's a thing what are they calling
that i'm gonna sound so old it's like
the doodle like
the nft is they're called doodles you
just get a doodle yeah and they're
selling for ridiculous amounts of money
like you could buy a porsche or you
could buy a doodle right i don't how is
this a thing
is it just people have so much money the
problem is everybody has has gotten so
much money over the last 18 months
because their stock market investments
have absolutely gone crazy their home
has gone crazy people are like flush
with there was there was government
money that came in especially to private
business owners that they didn't maybe
necessarily need but were forgiven
people i think it's all just it's
speculative it's just people thinking
that they've been okay
yeah crypto punks have gone up board
apes are
it's really expensive now and it's like
well this whole nft space is new yeah
and what if they come out with this
metaverse or the central land or there's
a sandbox
yeah
and so if i buy this well chances are
all these other people want to get into
and the crazy thing is that uh that most
people don't think about is that it is
difficult to buy an nft now like think
of it if you want to buy an nft
where do you go most people have no clue
and when it gets to the point where you
could go online and buy an nft like you
can on amazon
that's the point i think
the whole market is going to blow up
it's going to go so crazy for a few
months and then it's just the whole
thing's going to pop that's an
interesting point that's interesting
yeah but you're right that's a good
there's a lot of investments right now
probably that are being fueled by a
sense of having missed out yes
the car world it's very clear yeah like
people are paying crazy money for stuff
that just you're like
but part of me is like this is what
things cost now i think that people as
they age have a difficult time you
talked to older people about some of the
cars when they were younger and they're
like i remember when that was a six
thousand dollar used car and it's like
well things change and i think it's
difficult sometimes for people to
realize that that change has happened
like this is permanent this is what it
is now yeah and so maybe we're wrong and
this is just what things cost now
i think it's getting to the point where
you're seeing like friends or seeing
other people make a lot of money and
you're thinking well if they're doing it
yeah maybe i should do it um our friend
andre jic got i think he spent 15 000 on
a spider-man nft
it's worth a hundred thousand dollars
now a few weeks later
and it's worth in the sense that he's
sold it for that or like how do you
value this thing what other spider-man
nfts have sold for us so it's like same
with the cars like if you bought the car
well another four gt sold at this so
that makes mine worth that now
interesting similar enough that you can
value them in that way yes huh
yeah so within a few weeks 15 to 100 and
i'm thinking well you know if he's doing
that in a few weeks maybe you know
i should buy one you know maybe i try
this fine
sixth grade
exactly but when you start having those
thoughts usually that's the time it's a
terrible time
exactly but i wouldn't have bought it
for 15 to begin with this is one of the
reasons though i think that people
should largely invest in what they know
and why i've put up more money in cars
than i should but it's worked out
because i know i knew what cars were
going to go up in my opinion i knew i
was this is smart this is what's going
to be good and it has worked out it has
worked out handsomely and
if you do the nft thing because other
people are doing it maybe you're not as
sophisticated
yes
i would agree with that if you didn't
get the gt what would you have gotten
um i really
back then that's all i wanted i don't
know why the whole thing's weird i don't
know why i haven't i'm not like a
supercar guy
like i don't get into cars like that
um but i love that one
um i don't know what i would have gotten
i wasn't looking to just spend a ton of
money i just thought it would be cool
and i didn't think i'd have it long and
it's been now almost four years and i'm
not selling
um but there's other cars that i kind of
want or wanted before things went crazy
and
um i really wanted a porsche career gt
yep and i screwed that up i think
um but i couldn't have afford there was
no point where i could have comfortably
afforded it when i when i was close
enough i maybe could have bought a three
or four hundred thousand dollar car
comfortably and they were still 700 and
i guess i should have stretched because
now they're two yeah
what do you mean by you're not a
supercar guy i just like i like weird
car like i have this convertible g-wagon
i have this audi station wagon that's
like kind of got a weird backstory i
don't like
drive like mclaren's when i see that i
think like that's so gauche like i i
don't i wouldn't it's loud and it shouts
to everybody i don't i like him very
very like subtle and understated when it
comes to like showing i really i like
feel like a new englander when it comes
to like showing off i like don't do that
i like don't believe in like huge
displays of wealth and all that stuff
it's not my thing and so it's it's a
very odd thing for me to have a supercar
because like my it doesn't match my
personality that's special what would it
be in a car that would appeal to you
um like what would i get what yeah like
what in a car appeals i like to buy
iconic i really like to buy cars that i
view as iconic or is like very special
and unusual um this the audi station is
iconic because it was the first audi rs
car which has become this like vaunted
brand and because also it was built by
porsche in porsche's factory and those
are cool things and that sort of like
geekiness appeals to me i don't like the
cars where you're at the gas station and
a dude in a minivan walks up and says do
you want to trade like those aren't my
cars i like the cars where i'm driving
that audi and like one i've owned that
car 18 months and one guy has come up to
me and be like holy crap i cannot
believe this is here. and that is the
kind of conversation i will have for an
hour on the side of the road did that
person know who you were or they would
yeah no no no because like i really just
wanna and it was fine he still just
wanted to talk about the car which was
cool but like i would love i i i once a
year i get a conversation about cars
where the person has no clue who i am
and i savor the hell
it's a fun one to have to like hear
perspectives where they're not changed
by the fact that they know who they're
talking yeah
that's yeah that's interesting about the
wanna trade i i've gotten that bro
you want to trade yeah trade what kind
of gas mileage do you get how fast you
had it yeah i just want to be like and i
answer i'm very polite but at the same
time i'm thinking you're not a car
enthusiast and i didn't buy this car to
like have these conversations yeah like
i bought it because i'm really into it
and so like the cars that i'm
that i'm really into it's fun to have
conversations with other people who are
into it that's interesting see i've
because i rarely take out the gt and
it's been a while since i've driven the
lotus but uh i it's been so long since
someone says how fast have you taken it
but now i remember that was one of the
most common questions and people were
disappointed when i said the speed limit
and and that was kind of the
the real answer because i don't i get so
worked up about speeding yeah i just get
nervous and i'm like is it worth the
ticket
i i have just as much fun at 75 as i
imagine i would have it 1 30. yeah yeah
so i just i oh god i those are tough
ones and they're so cliche i hate any
sort of cliche conversation i can't do
those it's not my thing
and so that those are hard and that car
inspires it and that's the thing i don't
like about it and i don't like that
people are taking camera phones honestly
truthfully truthfully truthfully when i
bought that car i thought it would be
kind of subtle it's a ford it's dark
colored i didn't realize what would
happen which is people go nuts and
especially because that car has its
iconic status has increased in the last
few years in part because of the movie
yes and in part because the values have
gone up and people kind of are aware
that and the new one came out which i
think helped it too and and so it's the
reaction is wild taking that car out
people really go crazy what do you think
of the new one selling for a million
dollars because they because what are
they selling for msrp is 500 550 when
you got like 600 five to 650 depending
on the version got it and all of them
sell there's a floor of a million
dollars
um
i think people are buying it because
it's very scarce and it's very special
and that they know that
i don't think it's
to be diplomatic i don't think it's a
better car than ours
i love ours yeah it's a stick it's got
way more room the four dealers will work
on it people will work on it the new
ford gt you know who's the happiest
about new ford gts right now
is ford because they're running out of
warranty and ford doesn't have to put up
with this crap anymore those cars are
incredibly complex they were built in a
very complex factory and very in a very
complex way and i don't want to be stuck
with that thing in 10 years and also
it's like a race car have you been in
one of those it's tight and it's you're
sitting this this is the space you have
yeah between the dude next to you it's a
couple inches and it's like tight and
it's loud and it's rough and it's not
like ours ours are like a drivable
supercar which is the coolest thing
about it like you said it's ford it's a
the new one isn't like that and so i
don't know people are spending the
million dollars not to drive them it's
not for that it's not because it offers
some amazing experience you can't get
somewhere else
ford has said they benchmarked the
mclaren 675lt when they made the car
that's not that valuable the car
the the special thing about that car is
how rare it is right and i just
million bucks a lot do you think the
floor is going to stay at a million
yeah i don't think the car is the car is
desirable but i don't think it's insane
it's not a career gt it's not like a
true icon car when you look at the
performance numbers and everything i
don't think it's going to be i don't
think it's going to go down as like a 5
10 million dollar car one day um and i
think serviceability is going to be a
big part of that honestly got it what
cars do you think will become a car like
the carrera gt today because i think
we we missed the lexus lfa when those
were selling for like 350 lfa i think is
the most overrated car really this is
this is like very controversial
okay
it's an automatic lexus the transmission
is bad and i don't think the car looks
that good and i swear to god
i swear to god that if you didn't know
that it was worth 600 grand and you saw
one like if my wife saw it yet you would
have no clue you'd be like this is just
a car the lc which is lexus's current
sports car sporty car 70 80 grand
whatever looks better the lfa has a bad
transmission it has average looks and i
think it just went up like everything
went up and people think it sounds good
and they know it's rare and everything
rare is expensive but i think that's the
most overvalued car so what is going to
go up
all right i don't know it's an
interesting question i mean it's really
tough to figure that out i think the
ford gts still have a little bit of a
ways to go
i think lamborghini murcielagos
especially yes versions of them are
going to go on the sv the svs yeah
but even just the regular lp640s i think
um
it's just some cars it's just it's tough
to know
of course but anything that's special
now will only become more and more
special and the cool thing that the 4gt
has in the car gt has is being an analog
manual transmission car
you didn't know at the time but that
went that went away and i think as
hybrids and electric cars start to show
up even just having a gas engine will be
sort of thought of like a manual
transmission what other cars do you find
overvalued or overhyped yeah we want to
dig into this the lfa
the lfa nurburgring edition the lfa
track
um
i like the lfa i just it's 600 or
whatever it's insane you know lexus when
that car came out alexis hired a
full-time employee to go around the
country trying to get people to buy it
they took it to dealers he took it to
events wow desperate they were desperate
when that car came out lexus would only
let you lease it because they didn't
want people to buy it and flip it and
make money so you could only lease it
and then after a while they would let
you buy it and it was laughable
because nobody was speculating on that
car they were 500 sticker they were
worth instantly 250 nobody gave and
anyway now here we are and they're way
more expensive now they shouldn't be um
other cars that i think are overvalued
i think new ford gt frankly is a little
overview or even just overrated like
people make them up to be something
better than what they are that's a good
question i think
i don't know i'd have to think about
that if you look at virtually every
exotic car every special car that was
passed up at its time i had a whole list
of these the other day with my friends
that i was kind of going through that i
found interesting actually a good
example is the prior nsx the last
generation nx lasted all the way through
2005.
by the end no one wanted them they were
sitting in showrooms it was a disaster
and now those ones are the most
desirable and they are selling for huge
money for 200 000. not a bad example as
well yeah that car they had trouble
selling them at 06. oh five they sold
them to whoever's buying them by oh six
people pay was a lot of money for a ford
people nobody really wanted them they
had to cut production earlier career gt
was the same way they cut production
that car early which is insane to
imagine now and
here we are
and i think there's a lot of these
but in terms of other overvalued cars
and overhyped cars the best example is
air cooled porsches there's no question
80s and 90s porsches
people are now paying 100 grand for like
a regular one it's a joke cars not cars
are not that great it's not reliable uh
it's not particularly exciting there's a
million of them there you can't go to a
car show without seeing 25 air cooled
porsches they've all been well preserved
they're just i don't think they're that
special and i think that
some of these prices are just stupid
people
whenever whenever our car sells you know
a
two mile honda civic sells for big money
in 81 people freak out how could someone
pay for 30 grand for a honda civic no
way i'm freaking out like how could
someone pay a hundred for an 80s regular
80s 911 like that's
crazy to me talk about i'd rather buy an
nft
oh
and that says a lot
yeah jeez
what else what are there
is the ford gt your only special car no
so i have a load of sevora oh you have
oh really yeah yeah i've yet to actually
this first time i've mentioned it maybe
i think we've showed it off on the uh
it's the family before burying stuff in
after an hour barely i've i've well we
could keep this in there but uh i
haven't told anybody about buying this
car because i didn't want to make a deal
of it and i don't want to get because
the thing is it's chrome purple
i bought it so i bought it from our
friend anthony he was the poker guy and
he didn't have enough room in his garage
for his cars so he was like can i park
this in your garage i didn't mind and it
sat there for months
and he was like do you want to buy it
and he offered it to me at a price where
he's like i would be stupid for turning
it down he's like either i'm going to
turn it into i'm just going to basically
just give it into the dealer or whatever
they're going to give me this price but
if you give me this uh i'll sell it to
you it's like i may as well do it i've
had so much fun with that car yeah do
you feel as though your finances are
scrutinized extra by people like if you
were to announce that you got it
yeah see people don't understand if they
and i don't want to say how much i paid
for it but it was at a price where it's
like it would be impossible to lose
money on this car i'm making money if i
were to sell it but i wouldn't sell it
right but it's just the the the color
the aggression of the car the orange
calipers and little things it's just yes
people would immediately think that's a
waste of money right so do you have do
you feel like you have some
anxiety about
showing things like that like do you
have other stuff that you don't show
people because you don't want uh i don't
talk about prices of certain things like
the piano was something i could justify
so so i got this piano it was eighty
thousand dollars new
in 1980 so it was like this crazy piano
i paid 16 000 for it used but it's the
pianos are like cars like right certain
ones will either appreciate in value or
they stay the same this is a piano
that's 16 i could sell it for 16. i
could sell maybe 17. uh but certain
stuff like that people be like you spent
so much money on a piano but it's this
it's like a savings account yeah so
everything i buy
is a savings account there's the only
one thing that i've spent money on that
loses money is the aquarium that's the
one thing that's my one given yourself i
feel the same way i don't buy anything
unless i feel like it's either gonna
stay the same or make money i've made an
exception for my normal everyday car
just because i knew i'd be putting a lot
of miles on it and i didn't think i
could get away with it and plus i also
feel like having like a lot of safety
features and stuff is really important i
want to buy a new car or a pretty new
car but i agree i generally would prefer
to do that but there's you're not
holding any secrets out here where
you're like i don't know oh you know
what there's one thing i didn't oh well
i didn't i well i guess we did it on
this to family usually when i when i
mean like talking about is like usually
a main channel sort of thing but i
bought a patek philippe
a watch
and uh i thought you know it was a big
milestone kind of watch for me and but
it was a good value yeah and that's a
watch that uh
i got at a price uh federico hooked it
up from federico talks watches he gave
me his like rock bottom it's like not a
wholesale price but
you know but i didn't want to be like
hey guys i got this watch right so
i oh you know what i did hide the the
house i bought for a while yeah uh but
that was i closed on it a month and a
half before covet hit and i was planning
to do a house tour and i thought it
would be a really bad taste yeah yeah to
be like hey guys just bought this new
house well everything is shut down do
you not worry about privacy
no you don't worry is people going to
show up and no breaking in and kill you
knock on wood no i mean things never
happened nothing's ever happened until
it does gosh i mean here's the thing is
that first of all we have cameras
everywhere so if you if you approach
like everything's being recorded
everywhere so it's impossible that
someone can show up and we not have it
on camera
but everyone that i've met and for no
one's shown up but everyone one person
but he was a neighbor no
well i was it was someone that was
looking
at like the model homes and i like was
getting out of the car and i think that
they kind of came probably with some
ulterior motive like you know seeing if
they could see us in the front yard he
was like jacked as i was like walking
into the house oh which one said hello
yeah yeah um
but it wasn't anything bad it was like a
kid and his mom it was like totally
right but what if it
somebody never had a bad experience so
it's
is
the one person that did show up they
knocked on the front door and the guy
pulled up in a mclaren
and uh he wanted to introduce himself
because he lived down the street
and like i'd prefer
nobody knock on the door yeah um but
because he lived down the street i've
made it for neighbors i could justify it
but i didn't like it because it wasn't
like i wanted to introduce myself as a
neighbor it was hey i saw you bought the
house and you know it wasn't a
neighborly story he's not not doing this
with all the neighbors but still he's
just with me there and so you wanted me
and i could justify i couldn't drive in
from glendale no right no but everyone
that i've met otherwise has been so nice
and it's it's
watching there's crazy but it's finance
it's like and it's weird between
that increases it because you're saying
oh i have this much money i have this
much in this and that the people that
first of all the people that watch the
channel
know that the things i have very few
things of value
almost i'm so frugal in so many aspects
they're not getting that piano
good luck if you're trying to steal a
seven foot grand piano i mean of all
things to do
and you and we have cameras on the
inside too so like everything
would be would be recorded but uh i mean
people know how frugal i am the
aquarium's worth more than than anything
else i have no one stealing an aquarium
or just going in it's like taking a
piece of coral
but everyone in finance been so nice i
think it's a it's a more mature audience
they understand the aspects of like
saving money and it's different because
i was talking with james about this
strad man
and he was saying how often he'd have
people show up to his front door he
films in for every video in front of his
house i mean you're at some point
you're just kind of asking for like
something to happen like it's one thing
to be like insane and it's when you're
doing that and you're not living in a
gated community it's just kind of like
the way it's going to go right well the
v vegas is gated um and so is the place
in l.a so i mean both of them are gated
but um
i'm not so much worried about it but
you're you're right i probably should be
more i probably should be more careful
right you never i've i've had nothing
but good experiences yeah same i've had
you know countless thousands of people
come to me and every single interaction
has been nice but you just never quite
know you know
yes
you know have you ever had anybody not
be great when they meet you randomly no
have we no i don't think so everyone's
been really good yeah only thing that
would be an issue but it's not even that
big of an issue is sometimes they uh
take a lot of time yeah so it's not like
it's not just like hey you know i really
appreciate what you're doing like
they'll be there for like you know 10 15
minutes they keep going 20. like they
just the polite people are the ones who
met you decide because sometimes i got
10 minutes i'm like oh if i say
something interesting about like i have
a cool car
okay i want to hear more about that
but sometimes it's just in passing and
then it kind of takes you know yeah way
somewhere or something right yeah you
can never
uh really be in a hurry when you're just
kind of walking around in public right
right but everyone has really good
intentions yeah and sometimes it's like
you know even if they do take a lot of
time and i'm like i kind of i try to
make myself like i'm going to walk this
way now and they'll kind of walk with
you and the thing that i always say is
like this is a highlight for them of
their day yeah
and and the other day i was like
sometimes when you're not in a good mood
it's really tough if someone comes up to
you and you like just want to go to the
grocery store and buy something like go
home and just like sit
you're like
sad or whatever that's when it's hardest
because you've got to like kind of put
on a show for them because this is a
special thing for them and that's like
those are the worst ones
and that happens sometimes but how often
do you get seen in like the gt like what
what's the reaction you get in this um i
would flip if i saw you on the freeway
first of all i'd see a gt and it'd be
like oh my that
talked a mural
lose it i
maybe made a mistake being too open
about the cars because people now know
it's not just like oh wow i'm seeing a
convertible g wagon it's like oh that's
doug and i know and some people follow
you and i don't love that because i
don't know how that's going to turn out
when i stop i don't really want people
to follow me home or whatever
um but yeah the people recognize me in
the cars pretty often would the gt that
itself
expire inspires so much of a reaction
that it's hard to know
is it me or is it the car yeah
but the other cars yeah people people
know and they get excited and
i don't know you
you just hope they don't crash when
they're driving trying to take a picture
yeah yeah which
is sometimes a little sketching it yeah
it does seem like the car audience is so
much bigger though yeah with finance
it's like if you're if you're into
saving money you kind of know of the
channel or you're seeing a few videos
plus it's a hard charge like you said
right my audience tends to be a little
more mature than most car people because
i'm doing reviews stride man is out
there like vlogging his life and i think
that that incites he gets he has a huge
audience but i think that to some extent
there's just people kind of watching for
entertainment whatever a lot more of my
viewers are like just people yes looking
for a car i would say the difference
with james is that people watch him for
his personality yeah and that's the big
selling point yeah i personally and i
watch his videos i don't care what car
he buys i think that's cool that's the
best cool to hear him talk about it it's
just a backdrop prop for him yeah but i
think people watch him for him i think
even if it weren't cars if it were
bicycles yeah he would have the same
sort of attraction
and people feel like they know him from
those videos because he's just so much
of himself yeah i think that that's true
and i think doing car reviews it's a
little bit less like that people are
just here they need to get a car and so
i i'm not that concerned people are
generally relatively mature and that
kind of thing but
you just you open yourself up to like
the wholesale public
and there's something that's like
yeah but i'm always just worried i guess
my my biggest concern is sometimes we'll
we'll have a very private conversation
and uh the person next to us will be
listening yeah and i remember having it
once where i
i never thought of it as an issue but i
was having a talk with somebody else uh
who worked for somebody else and it was
a very private conversation and and
after he got up or he he was leaving and
the lady next to us listened to the
entire thing and she's
not to me to the other guy by the way i
i want to say i love your work i i
didn't want to bother you guys because i
i knew you're in a conversation but like
i really enjoy it i just want to say hi
but i was like wow like what did this
person i mean it was nothing bad
just private that you have to be more
careful it is interesting
you can't yell at the comcast people on
the you know you never know who knows
you and who might you know
you have to be like super at any given
moment you have to assume that whatever
you say might go viral
yeah i want to yeah i do want to mention
this but i don't want to give enough
details because i know this person's
watching but i had a uh
i got something
and the other person i i was not happy
with the other person
and i thought about like leaving a bad
review or something because i
i thought this i don't want to say what
it was but i wasn't happy with it
at the end
uh
i got the i'm a huge fan of your channel
yeah i watch all the videos i mean a lot
to me if i could just get a picture yeah
like anything and and that was like oh
yeah no absolutely but i'm so glad that
i was just like you know write my tongue
and yep yeah yep that's exactly right i
did my wife and i went on our honeymoon
went to new zealand and we did a glacier
a helicopter to a glacier to do an ice
hike
and the dude gives us the whole tour of
the glacier it was really cool one of
the coolest things i've ever done land
on the glacier and the helicopter and we
watched we do all the stuff and we used
the little ice shoes and everything and
it was like two hours and at the very
end of it the dude was like by the way
i'm like i didn't want to say anything
but i'm a huge fan and i was like i'm so
glad that i was like nice and you know
yeah
yeah it makes it worse to find out after
the fact i'd rather just know up front
what have i said
i would much rather know up front and
that's like you know uber drivers or
like because he knew that if he had said
something maybe the conversation turns
to cars my wife is there and she just
wants to see the mount you know a
glacier and like i get it and so that
was a cool way to do it but at the same
time it puts a lot of pressure on you
what did i do gosh
i am curious about income sources yeah
um
how would you say they're broken down on
your channel because i noticed i don't
see any sponsorships yeah
my channel is an interesting thing
because i feel like as a car reviewer i
feel like i'm more of a journalist than
a
entertainer and so i don't feel too
comfortable doing sponsorships
um because i start to feel like if
you're getting paid then your
objectivity
gets questioned and the
quality
the truth to what you say your veracity
is just all kind of getting questioned
i've always wondered if that was the
right move
because all everybody else does
sponsorships but i i kind of feel like
the numbers have proved me right like
the fact that my channel has always
stayed so big and that people are always
watching and have always believed
that
i'm truthful and i'm like the guy they
can trust
i think that now that over time the
numbers have proved me right that like i
was right not to do sponsors i think um
i do a few here and there but it's
really rare and for that reason i'll
tell you from our experience well jack
i'll actually let you answer this one
were you about to say something i was
just gonna ask if uh car makes have ever
paid you or offered to pay you to um
yeah this is one of my like biggest
annoyance topics about the car
journalist industry i don't know if you
guys know how car reviews are done but
the way a car review is done the
automaker sends an email and says hey
guess what we're launching a new car
subaru legacy i'll give you as an
example
um
and the way it's going to work is you
can fly
out with your spouse to big sur
to this beautiful hotel property you get
your own
uh
little hut villa thing on this beautiful
hotel you can use the spa the while
we're doing the product briefing your
wife spouse can use the spa can get a
massage can enjoy the property
then you go drive the car in this
beautiful drive down highway one you
park at the end of the day we feed you a
fantastic dinner
and then we look forward to your
objective review and by the way the
automaker paid for all of this
and
um not only do i not accept literal cash
from the automakers but i am the only
car reviewer currently in existence who
doesn't take those trips so they reach
out and they say hey we're doing this
big sur thing
and i say to him great i'm gonna i'm
gonna book a room at the comfort inn in
paso robles and you tell me when i have
to be at the at the event to drive the
car and i'll be at the event i don't get
dinner paid i don't get flights paid i
don't get hotels paid and i really think
that that's the correct way to do it and
none of my rivals do that now they will
sit there and say we don't take money
from automakers but you kind of do
because that trip to big sur is kind of
an experience that's it's not free like
they didn't pay you for your they didn't
get you that room to have an objective
review of the car
they got you that room because they
wanted to butter you up so you would say
these things and so directly no an
automaker has never offered a payment
i've never taken payment but indirectly
i think they're all paid and you should
look very skeptically when you see car
reviews especially when car views all go
up on the same day and you notice that
all the pictures are in the same place
that's because they all went to some
five-star hotel in some special place
and got some crazy perks to give an
objective review of the car in an
objective at all
ever gosh that reminds us of uh the
channel we've received so many requests
from people who want to pay to be
featured yeah and some of them i gotta
say are so tempting yeah because it's a
lot of money yeah but we've never done
it because don't you think your audience
like i feel like that's that's you
that a lot of money comes in that day
but long term your audience is like he's
getting paid yeah well i just like
saying we've never paid
we've never been paid to have a guest on
and and you can't say that
if one of them even if you do 500
episodes if one was paid then you can't
say we've never done that yeah and you
can maintain
this era of like being kind of high and
mighty and i'm kind of holier than now
about this but i can be because i've
never
taken i've never done this
and that gives me i think an objectivity
that a lot of my rivals don't have and i
think it's an objectivity that a lot of
the viewers appreciate and i suspect the
same is true yeah but i do think for
sponsorships i don't think anybody would
mind
yeah i probably need to do more and i've
been thinking about that this year and i
would just be careful about the sponsors
you pick yeah but i think it's not car
brands right but i think if you did a
good sponsorship with a great brand um
to integrate that's right i would like
to do more with especially products that
i like believe in and that i know are
good yeah so i think you could do that
really well even uh what it was the
raycon headphones or
something like that
i think would be
yeah or audible something that you could
do you know if you if you want to listen
to an audiobook and you
want to have a headphone in when you're
driving yeah yeah yeah no that's
probably true i probably should do more
and i think i should do more that space
and honestly
even just within the last few weeks i've
reached out to a couple people that i
hadn't in the past asking about i would
pursue it i think
for the amount of value that you provide
in a video a 20 25 minute long video i
think halfway through
having a sponsor no one would bat an eye
yeah or especially because everyone else
literally everyone else yes
it's gotten so good the other thing is
you could negotiate because you have so
much leverage to put it at the very end
of a video where you know you'll get
paid half
but it's there and it's there it's at
the very end i didn't know it was even
on the table yeah so drew negotiate
anything in the sponsor i didn't think
of course but i didn't think a sponsor
would even want like go for that yes
drew gooden always does it
yeah he's another channel
because if he did integrations in the
middle it'll kind of throw off the flow
of the video and that's my biggest thing
i don't mind doing sponsors now my
biggest worry is will it throw off the
flow of a video if it will i won't do a
sponsor because i'm i care more about
the video itself but if it won't if
there's no harm in it then then i'd i'd
like to do that yeah yeah that makes
sense that makes sense and automotive is
rife with this i mean this is a big deal
in automotive because i like it's not
quite the same as finance but our
viewers are also pretty wealthy pretty
in the world of buying stuff obviously
if you're watching car reviews
you probably have some money et cetera
it's not like you know some stupid vlog
about whatever
um and so the sponsors pay pretty well
yeah i would do that i think you would
be shocked yeah how different the income
would look yeah when you look when you
take into account sponsors yeah yeah
that's probably true like i thought here
the ad revenue was uh was the main you
know creme de la creme but as you begin
expanding you realize it's only a
portion of it yeah yeah yeah but how is
your income broken down in the sense of
like ad revenue cars and bids could you
talk like a percentage um i'm not
pulling much money out of cars and bids
yet um
so as a result the youtube ad revenue is
like the absolute primary driver almost
all of my income comes from that and it
has for a long time um
now
part of the reason that i'm not pulling
money out of cars and bids yet is
because it's still growing and we're
trying to reinvest in that sort of thing
and i could if i wanted to but um and i
see that as hopefully a long term a more
long term like
the income play like we've discussed
um
but yeah i mean ad revenue has just been
it's been fantastic it's been consistent
and that's been that's like my huge
driver yeah have you thought about
offering anything other than cars and
bids like maybe something you're more
involved in whether it be like uh i
don't know
for us we have like programs do a course
yeah is there something like that
and i think that's probably a future
thing honestly the thing about cars and
bids is like right now it's my thing and
i'm doing it but
i think it's almost you're almost at
that point like with your kid learn how
to ride a bike where you kind of can
push it and let it kind of do its thing
without quite as much of my involvement
and so then the question is what do you
do next now what i've been telling
everybody is i don't want to do any more
of this
it's a lot of work starting the channel
and getting to where i got has been a
lot of work and then launching this
business was a lot of work and so i
think i do want to do something like
yeah like that or like a podcast where
it's it's not like
building a business quite necessarily i
don't want to i'm good like i'm just
good you know what i would do
doug de 2 the second channel more doug
demuro i'd start posting on there weekly
with sponsors yeah
that's what i would do that way the main
channel stays intact you you keep all of
that
uh to yourself yeah but i think the uh
more doug de miro yeah that might make
sense once a week i took all the more
doug videos not off but since about
march i've been posting the more doug
videos on my main channel on sundays and
maybe it would make sense to go back and
do sponsors on the other i like the sit
down talks in your garage same i love
them they're easy yes but i think you
have to be a certain type of like
interested person to like appreciate
them they certainly have been interested
in you you have enough interested people
i do yeah yeah surprisingly yeah i can't
believe your interested audience is my
entire main channel on an average video
is your interested audience it's nuts
because i'm looking at the vid the views
on your second channel they're really
really really high they're good yeah so
that's what i would do become even
better so i moved those i started doing
those videos last march on my main
channel on sundays and they're even
better now yeah and it's like because
i'm surprised some of the videos that
you post on i i would think this is main
channel worthy yeah but it's like
yeah in retrospect i wish that i had
done some things a little different like
the rolls-royce one i was like how is
that on the second channel was i was
always feeling like if i deviated it all
on the main channel that it would screw
up my algorithm on the main channel and
over time i have discovered that the
algorithm is a little bit more
sophisticated than that and you can post
a stupid video on a sunday that only
gets a couple hundred thousand views and
then go back to getting a million views
on tuesdays and thursdays where i
normally post and it actually is capable
of handling that i don't think it always
was i have a theory that it wasn't at
some point i have a theory based on some
other people's
uh performance that they started posting
some kind of second rate stuff and it
took sort of slid the whole channel but
i think now it's capable of realizing
okay sundays he posts it's less good
that's so mean it's gonna happen my
experience uh is always the youtube
algorithm is forgiving
of two bad videos in a row
that's that's it so if i have one bad
video it's like okay the pressure's on i
have one more mess up if i mess up that
second video if the third is not a
banger
it takes months to recover from that
that's been my experience you know i
will tell you though one one benefit i
have with car reviews is at least once
or twice a month i can get an insane
video because new cars come out to a
level so like lucid air rivien i knew
those videos would blow up they did blow
up and you can be pretty strategic about
where you can put them if you have a
couple bad videos three or four even you
can put a rivien up next and everything
is all smoothed over at that point and
you probably don't have quite the same
ability to like snap your fingers and
say this is going to blow up it is
interesting but one good video i've
noticed youtube puts you in a tier
and you'll you'll get views within a
certain range yeah and you need one
video that blows those metrics that will
boost you into the next tier
and then
that next video afterwards is going to
be
pushed in that tier but if you're not
able to sustain that on your own then
you get boosted you get dropped back
down you're
you know back to the average like i
don't know any of the other car
youtubers really accept a text they all
kind of view me as like the grandfather
of car youtube and so they all kind of
reach out for advice periodically yeah
but like i don't generally
have like other people who are in the
youtube space partially because i find a
lot of other youtubers to be kind of
difficult to deal with that's
interesting because that's all who we
talk like every single one of my friends
everyone who i see on it on like on a
daily basis is another youtuber and
almost all of them are in the finance
space i lived next door to uh jeremy
who's another financial agent youtubers
i could imagine being more because
you're you're starting from kind of a
higher baseline but like some of my car
youtube colleagues i don't know how much
this you watch there's some interesting
characters out there
but see for us this is the same thing as
being like you know introduced hey
what's your net worth yeah what do you
make last month oh yeah how many high oh
yeah you should fire some people though
you should get that cost down margins
are too thin because that's what we talk
about so it's interesting to to see
other people's like because to me it's
normal and all of us uh like a few weeks
ago were like hey is your ad revenue
down 30 this month yeah mine too let me
text a few more people and find out yeah
theirs is down as well something's going
on interesting so all of us are in it
interesting yeah and we all compare
analytics so i wonder how long have you
been doing it five years
i've got so much past analytics that
like when the ad rates go down a little
for the seasonally or whatever i'm not
all that surprised i i'm not i don't
really get that surprise anymore for
that sort of but this january is
substantially worse than every other
january job interesting have you noticed
that no actually surprisingly this was
my best january ever
is that because no but is that because
ad revenue is up or is that being the ad
rate was not as high as i think the
address
same reason the views were way up and so
yes so i'm talking about ad rates so
when you look at the cpm i'm not sure
what that would be
this year for my january was about the
same as last year which is unusual
because in all prior years
almost every month over month it's
always been improving and so i i
actually have started in my mind
wondering like have we hit a
are we that's interesting yeah because
everyone that i've talked to
says it's down twenty to thirty percent
over the last january uh no this is the
biggest drop we've ever seen from
december to january okay yeah and that
includes other other uh channels but
you're the first one
i had a big drop from december i always
do i don't really look at december
versus january though because i don't
really find it relevant since they're so
different and i also i kind of goose
december i have this thing called doug
sember where i put up insane content i
like start shooting in june and i like
put up insane content specifically in
december because i know the rate's going
to be so high so i tend to make
20 i tend to make december's double for
me i make double the money on an average
other month in december and so
december's like a really big deal for me
so like lucid air rivien uh the mercedes
eqs has been a big deal a lot of like
really i like the rivian one yeah
that video blew up yes and that was i
put that on black friday i have no shame
i have no shame in admitting what i did
there that's a big day
and it did well
how many mid roles do you put in a video
a bunch
three i think four something like that
oh you could do more than that i
probably could i probably could but i
just wanted to start in the end too yes
so you know yeah it's the only time i i
see i don't mind mid-rolls on the phone
i do mind them on the tv
that's the only time when i'm watching a
video on the tv because it's hard to
like yeah yeah you got to find the
remote click it off no and people get
upset and annoying although my view is
like get premium it is insane to me that
people will spend as much time
complaining as they do when for whatever
premium quest like 11 a month or
something 15. like come on yeah i i got
premium i hadn't had premium for years
it never even occurred to me for some
reason and one of my friends was like
you don't have premium and i got it like
six months ago and i haven't seen an ad
sense and people like i have this ad
blocker and that ad blocker and i do
this and then it's like just pay the
money
i do that to uh download videos and then
you could also close your phone and
listen to the video and that's so
important yeah that's the best so that's
why i pay for it yeah the premium yeah
yeah
so but that is interesting yeah no
january so far january was fine okay but
it's always but it's always a
significantly enhanced drop for me
because i like really goose november
december and because i actually
intentionally thus put up
videos i know aren't going to do as well
in january why burn good videos when the
ad rate is so bad i agree but those some
of my january videos are some of my
favorites because it's like the weird
stuff that i can't do when the ad rates
are good because it won't get enough
views so actually my january february
content tends to be like some of the
more fun videos but see the sponsorships
are good because it's it's more stable
yeah sometimes you'll sign a year-long
contract yeah and so your december is
going to be the same as january is the
same as june yeah and it's just it's
that stability that i really appreciate
yeah that makes sense what do you think
you could work on
that could make your videos better and
how do you plan on understanding that
shorts
no i don't know i probably i will do
some sponsors but other than that like i
don't know it's tough when you're like
look at all the other car review
channels like i'm still number one i'm
ahead of them all i don't know like how
else to grow this dramatically other
than kind of what i've been doing so i'm
gonna tell you the two honestly and we
just talked about them i think sponsors
i think if you sprinkle them in every
now and then
i think all you need is three good
brands yeah that you could work with
consistently and you have three every
month with the same brands and your
audience is going to appreciate the
consistency yeah because they know
you're not going to be promoting
something you know some crappy product
or whatever a good product and you could
charge a premium because you don't do it
yeah you could use that i think also
shorts i've experimented with shorts now
the short audience is totally different
really from the long-form audience and i
i was not expecting that but
every time i posted shorts you see like
the new viewers and returning viewers
the new viewers spikes way higher than
the return huh interesting yeah so it's
getting pushed to a new audience and i
think for 60 seconds you could come up
with the best quarks and features for
sure and i think it would complement it
just the way you're already doing the
shorts the thing the reason i haven't
done it is because i'm worried that
doing something like that has a negative
effect on
the other videos yes i'm still testing
it out from what i've seen the shorts
have no impact on the main channel that
like on the normal this has to be true
in order to for people to justify
wanting to do that correct i think
youtube would be
wanting people to post i thought the
same thing i'm like if i post a short
is this going to affect my click-through
rate yeah are they or
you know if someone skips past that does
that screw everything up or is the watch
time going to mess it no um interesting
so from what i've seen conservative
about new features yeah i would try it
be cautious about it i'm still testing
it out myself but i've had nothing but a
positive experience the one thing i have
noticed which is interesting is that i
had one short that was doing really
really really well and i thought well
it's been a week since i posted a short
i'm going to post a new short now the
new short posted the previous one
completely cut off that very minute
interesting so i saw the views basically
drop the interest and the other short
went up but the new short wasn't doing
as well as the previous one so you wish
you would just so
youtube is more likely to push a new
short than an old one even if the old
one is more even if the old one's better
and if the new one's better youtube i
think analyzes that one as not being the
newest so it's not going to promote the
new one because it's not good even
though the old one is better yeah so i
don't i i think there's still something
they're working around there interesting
we've also seen in the past where
youtube has an interest in pushing out
like their their newer features such
yeah posts where you do that like
remember how that would blow up your
channel right oh yeah the polls exactly
but it's the same as what i've noticed
with a with a long form video when i
post a new video
that takes priority for the for the
recommended yeah so i think same thing
with shorts but the two are separate at
least interesting that's good to know
yeah so how is your time allocated and
walk us through very briefly an average
day in the life of doug demure um it
depends on whether i'm like filming that
day or not if i'm filming that's like a
lot of the day i would say the majority
of the day um like wake up go sometimes
i'm driving two three hours up to la
film a video drive two three hours home
it's kind of a disaster um when i'm not
doing that a lot of the time is spent on
cars and bids i do a lot of the um
reserve setting on cars and bids which
is interesting because you can imagine
people have different opinions about the
value of their cars we do it sometimes
it gets kind of funny
um and i just do a lot of supporting of
my team there i edit every single
listing in the end i like have an editor
who does it but i like give it one final
look over and then i write my little
take on each one so that takes some time
um so a date can kind of depend it can
kind of depend on exactly what's being
done that day sometimes my entire day is
filming and i don't i can't look at a
thing on cars and bids and i trust my
staff does it and sometimes it's like a
purely cars and bids day where i don't
have any real videoing to do and where
do when do you generally start working
and when do you cut it off i like wake
up at 5 30 or 6 now and i can't seem to
stop that i've came from the east coast
and i used to wake up at nine and i
moved with the time difference
annoyingly um and so i start working
almost right away i'm really fresh in
the morning i can do stuff really really
well in the morning i hate afternoons
more than anything in the world i like
like to nap i hate like the time between
like one and four any questions for us
um
no
i don't think so
what do you what did you think of stream
man
i liked him a lot he's he's the nicest
guy he's most a genuine person yeah it's
crazy he is exactly the same and i could
say the same thing about you exactly the
same on camera as off and it's it's
incredible with him how easy it is for
him to film
like he'll just whip out the camera
one take
with like perfect energy
and it'll just
be right back huh it's like how did you
do that i would have taken 20 tickets
you ever meet some people where you're
like wow
they're different
no like they suck
oh like you obviously are meeting a lot
of people to space obviously you don't
have to name names but you ever meet
anybody you're like i don't want to be a
part of this person there were two
uh one
was uh
someone who i like really looked up to
and uh it's it's not kevin o'leary by
the way kevin o'leary by the way i was
shocked i came in i came in like so ner
i thought he was just going to be like
just pure get in get out
and he hung out with us afterwards like
then and he showed up alone which i was
like
are you i thought
oh that's cool kevin is amazing uh the
one which i kind of get now was a it was
just a busy person
and um
basically just told me all right we have
45 minutes and just
showed up
uh i was kind of setting up
had no interest in any conversation yeah
filmed
perfect and then immediately after just
was like all right let's see it that was
it huh and so it was just a bit
disappointing because it's like you'd
like to kind of hang out i don't expect
it but it would just be kind of nice
um because otherwise i just feel like
well then it's just for the youtube and
yeah you know um and then the other one
was just
uh
i traveled to see this person
and then
you know i i made some commitments
of what was expected from me and uh
immediately after showing up i was like
i want to get out i just it was it was
not for me it was not what i expected
and so uh so i cut ties yeah yeah yeah
interesting but everyone else was was
good i'll tell you after filming but
but yeah but no everyone else was
fantastic yeah
and everyone has become a friend
everyone that we've had on the podcast
we keep in touch with oh that's nice
yeah
interesting it would be fun by the way
to get like all once a year this is
never going to happen a once a year we
rent out like a warehouse like this
invite everyone on the podcast in one
place one time i would love to do it too
it's like a convention
that's like a thing that would be a nice
coffee convention
let's do it
i would love to do it i'll pay to help
rent out all right a thing i would do it
okay people just have to get their own
accommodations but we'll provide we'll
provide punch and pie sure
okay
pizza and pie
okay time cool yeah people are generally
very nice in this space at least the
people that i've met i've had great
experiences with them all yeah that's
good it's good to know because you never
always wonder you know yeah how was it
with us by the way because i was really
nervous i i had planned out the trip
perfectly but the charging took a little
bit too long and there was traffic i was
five minutes late i felt so bad oh no i
was late and and it was great i um i'm
blown away by your setup in the sense
that my setup is a disaster in
comparison i'm always shocked at how
much
year people have that's like the biggest
thing that always surprises me
um because i just don't yeah
and i'm always surprised like oh this is
what a real
real deal
this is how it's supposed to look
i don't think so see i i i really envy
the way you you run everything i like
the fact that it's so simple it's it's a
special thing to be able to do it yeah
easily but
it would be also nice to you know know
what i don't even know what any of this
talked about yes you should see our
actual setup like our actual studio it's
a room where you just sit down and press
the button and we have a switchboard
yeah and we have lights everywhere it's
it's amazing yeah yeah i mean it always
blows me i was saying before we were on
camera this i did this film this
commercial with audi and like i just
can't believe how much goes into this
kind of stuff like obviously with movies
i know you see the trucks around and you
know what's insane they shot off streets
and all that but like we did a
commercial it took it was a minute of
screen time
i mean there were truly a hundred people
there there were trailers as if there
were actors on set like there were it
was wild i just can't believe it's some
of the stuff and everybody everything
like i press the button i like listen to
the sound all of myself they have a guy
for every single one of these jobs and
it just like blows me away like i've
seen them filming with netflix for
selling sunset and the amount of people
yeah uh just to be in a room yeah
filming one thing you're right there's a
person like monitoring the audio and a
person monitoring that person the person
checking the lighting and a person
watching behind the scene and like five
people giving you it's nuts it's nuts
yeah it's just crazy i cannot believe
some of the setups this is nothing in
comparison but to me this is right now
but no i like your approach and uh
that's what i've done for my channel as
well yeah it's one camera lights on that
we don't even have lights on these uh
you don't even have towels on the lights
people care about the content yeah and
that's what i always tell people i still
get people coming to me and being like
i'm gonna make the best car channel ever
with 4k drones and i'm going to do all
this stuff and like i'm always
encouraging of people who say this to me
but like
you're not going to see a return forever
and it sounds like you're going to spend
a lot of money to not see a return and
also i just don't think that's what
people are looking for necessarily i
think that people want content none of
that stuff matters if that stuff if you
have content and that stuff it's great
but like
that will not get you anywhere you need
to have something that people want to
see that's where it all starts to me
and if you want to pad it after that
with some of that stuff then that's
something i guess
i'd say that's good that's good to end
it there unless you had i think that's
good little
thank you doug nice to meet you yeah
nice to meet you thank you so much for
doing this yeah i've been looking
forward to this since we first uh got in
touch when i bought the gt yeah and uh i
can't believe today's the day i don't
know i think we did it i'm so glad we
did it
thank you so much thank you i'm glad i'm
happy to be here i'm excited for this to
post guys uh we'll link to your channel
down below in the description i'm sure
everyone you don't need an introduction
but uh anyway
all your info is down below in the
description you guys gotta subscribe you
have to do it and uh hit the like button
get a free stock down below and uh until
next time thank you
thank you